to ask questions about evolution uh
and you've you've been responsible for
some uh
some very interesting meetings of santa
barbara which is
i think kind of being one of the
inspirations maybe for what we're doing
here
so thank you
well
it's a great pleasure
and
also a bit of a challenge because
i really wish i was here from the very
beginning
and this way i would
have a much better
understanding of where
all of you are and where all of us are
and
but
anyway so uh
hopefully
with your questions
and uh
my uh attempt to to be flexible
we can
sort of
synchronize a little bit so my
assignment was to present you with the
statistical physics views of evolution
i don't know if i can
actually manage that but
i will at least hope to present a
statistical physicist's view of
evolution
and
roughly
um
again because i don't quite know
what
you've been doing this uh
this week
uh i will start with uh a little bit of
review of uh basic elements just to get
us to use the same
language
and uh well again i guess repetition is
the mother of learning
and uh
maybe at least i'll give you a little
bit uh something that you already know
from a different angle and that might be
useful and most of all
please don't hesitate to fast forward me
and
i will try to do it myself
and
my other
assignment was to try to present you
with
some
big picture
of you which
one really shouldn't uh
probably ever ask me to do because uh
you know oscar here was uh
uh doing heavy lifting of actually
telling you about facts and if you start
asking me for a big picture i will
sort of go off into the land of dreams
so but
i threw in so a couple of philosophical
interludes that i normally wouldn't
and i guess we'll also use this as a
little bit an opportunity to to provoke
so um
but the
oscar with
the heavy lifting has set up
much of
the story that i want to tell you for
example he was talking about
this little model of a asexual
adaptation as a traveling wave and
i'm going to take you through this in a
little bit more detail
and in part two we will
go from asexual to
sexual or at least sometimes sexual
i.e
um
things like
yeast and
plants that do not have to outcross in
order to
make babies all the time and then
recombination is so facultative it
occurs only every so often and in fact
becomes
a parameter becomes a tunable knob in
this case not only a knob in the model
but
an evolutionary knob
so we'll talk about
interplay of genetic interactions
and
recombination
and
okay
let's
jump in so
we very often think of evolution
certainly that's how it's viewed in
um
you know the press as
something that looks into the past that
has to do with the origins and then we
observe the leaves and if we want to
find common ancestors we have to go and
dig in
sedimental rock
but
uh the excitement that uh i think uh has
attracted quite a few physicists yeah
this is my statistical physics
connection here um to to the to the
subject is that these days there's
completely different kind of data
so of course evolution is a dynamical
process and
with the fast evolving bugs such as rna
viruses
like hiv uh the dynamics of evolution
is basically
um
they have the development of the disease
itself and uh there is a kind of
there's data like this
that
basically represents
it presents a tree constructed from
genomic sequence
genomic samples
of
hiv
harvested from blood samples of a single
patient
over the course of
well what about 14 years here so every
half a year a patient
went to the clinic blood sample was
taken and eventually viruses
extracted
and sequenced at least some of them and
then based on sequence sequence
relatedness a tree was reconstructed and
the striking feature was that
uh initially there was very little
diversity it was basically one strain of
virus identified in blood but very
rapidly there was a great burst of
diversification and that went on and on
and on
uh
as time progressed in this chronic
disease and there is a fair bit of data
of the sort invariably one sees a great
deal of sequence divergence so basically
between these early strains and let's
late strains there's almost 10 percent
divergence i.e
10 of all the nucleotides in this
sequence sequenced segment of the virus
actually got
substituted so that that's amazing to
see that much diversity um
rather that much divergence
in drosophila would
have to look at the
species separated by
100 million years
and
because
oh i'm sorry two many
why did i say 100 many
in any case million years
so here you
um see that much diversity divergence
occur
basically in a single patient over a
very
uh short period of time
and of course it is driven by
the competition between the virus and
the immune system the immune system is
uh
constantly
developing
so affinity for the virus it recognizes
the virus kills it and the virus then is
under pressure to change the antigens
and escape the detection from the immune
system
so that that's
one mechanism in fact that was
operating at the time of the experiment
it was done so these days actually
it is hard to come up with
a data of that sort because patients get
treated
and
instead
we're doing uh effectively a different
kind of
experiments now the virus has to compete
rather evolve to acquire drug resistance
so in this particular case i'm showing
the sequence of
amino acids of drug sensitive
strain
and
another sequence now which is drug
resistant and you see quite a few
substitutions
and remarkable thing here is that
well clearly not all of these
substitutions are required for
resistance but
typically
many are and
and it is actually essential for
the drug
to actually be
effective
that it would require multiple
substitutions in order to be defeated so
and the the challenge of course is
that
this rna virus is mutating very fast
so this mutational rate
times genome length corresponds to what
about
0.3
mutations per genome generation
and
the viral load in an untreated patient
is rather gigantic so there's a large
number of viruses
excuse me
the generation time is uh well actually
i think depends on condition depends on
the cell type but
roughly two days at least that's in cell
culture
so
okay
so
with this mutation rate and population
size
basically
every single substitution in the genome
is tried in a single generation in fact
every pair of substitutions is tried in
a single generation right so the drug
that takes only two mutations
to uh to beat is virtually worthless
right so that's basically the idea
behind the you know drug cocktail so you
want to apply multiple drugs to make
sort of an evolutionary landscape for
for the virus
a little bit more
complex that makes tons of sense but
you see stuff in the literature where
they're saying like this is the drug
resistance mutation and the
absolutely don't talk about the rest
what's going do you have any sense of
what's going on there well so there is
actually a fair bit of
of uh knowledge that there is a
whole database of resistance strains and
there is uh some repertory of
substitutions that uh
uh
contribute to resistance
and one is actually trying to enumerate
um these different combinations and uh
so an active study of these uh
mutational landscapes
and uh
there's very nice data available in this
field because
people actually reconstruct strains
adding one substitution at a time and
then measure the effect
and there's nice quantitative data that
one can actually try to address the
question of
reconstructing
this
fitness in that case drug resistance
um
uh or drug susceptibility landscape as
you add
more generation right
so how much does it take typically for a
patient when they get so infected to
become resistant do they know that well
i think in practice it's uh well it
depends on the drug
okay i don't understand the treatment
um
well under so standard okay
strictly speaking uh i should just say
that i don't really know this in enough
detail to give you
uh a good answer
so i'll uh
i'll
uh
uh plony pennies at stanford has done a
lot on this right
and uh i think they find it a lot of
times it happens right away practically
that it's already in the standing
diversity in the population the drug
resistance mutations
um
if it doesn't happen right
away it can take
uh
i think
months to years
well it depends uh depends on the drug
and it depends on on the treatment right
and of course the treatments are
designed to sort of maximize the time so
if you ask
you know what does it take
in a clinical setting the answer is i
don't know
so
okay so
uh this is not the whole story um
not everybody
knows that uh
hiv
engages in a kind of viral
sex of of its own so it's an rna
virus in order to
proceed with its life cycle it has to
copy
its rna into dna there is a reverse
transcriptase that does the job it binds
uh
rna template starts making a dna copy
but it's a bit sloppy so it falls off it
falls off while holding on to
this partially copied dna
and then it reloads another rna strand
and just picks up where it uh stopped so
as long as
there is only
one type of a template in
the cell
it will
right make a faithful copy but if the
cell is multiply infected then there is
a chance that it will
pick up the other strand
right and the babies will come off as
mosaics of of the two different strands
so that is exactly the same
outcome as
so the outcome of familiar sex and
recombination basically taking
different strains and
bringing
um
genetic
polymorphisms from different strains
onto
the same genome
and
and again in the context of this problem
basically understanding
the
rate of acquisition of drug resistance
as a function of okay mutation rate well
mutation rate uh you don't change very
much but uh
the
size of viral population the patient is
certainly itself successful susceptible
to the drug level so you may ask
is it worth increasing the drug dose to
completely
suppress
the population size so how much
does the rate of drug
um
rate of evolution of drug resistance
depend on the population size and
this is going to depend
also on the role of
recombination here since
of course the probability of a
multiple infection itself is uh at least
the quadratic function of
viral density
so
uh i guess this is my my big picture
slide so i just uh on two previous
slides
gave kind of two views of evolution
evolution looking at uh
the origins looking at the past
and the evolution
of uh
right as a
dynamical process
uh defining the future as in acquisition
of drug resistance for example
and uh um
this
dynamics
as has been said can only be understood
in the context of population genetics
which describes the spreading of alleles
in
populations but
it is of course directly related to
molecular
and systems biology and genetics which
actually defines
the
phenotype genotype relation now all of
biology can be you might say captured in
this one function relation of phenotype
to the genotype and
when oscar was discussing distribution
of
mutation effects
right
on some level
this is
a molecular genetics question and
systems biology question
um
what do we know about the effects of
tweaking
this biological system
what effect
how many ways are there to
affect a given genotype be it
drug sensitivity or
you know height
or oil content
and
then of course there is uh ecology
which uh
defines actually a notion of fitness it
defines
what selective pressures there are in
acting on this organism and in fact
whether there are some additional ways
of avoiding the selection
pressures as i think monty
i mentioned
so
the dream
of a statistical physicist
is
then somehow to unify
these uh you know three lines of
inquiries distilling
the
uh essence let me call this statistical
genetics
which uh
would allow
predicting the evolutionary future
in some statistical sense
so by this i mean
actually understanding the distribution
of
mutational effects
understanding
how
likely we are to find sort of lots of
small jumps or perhaps
few very
very
big jumps
understand
at least on some statistical level
so the likelihood of
or rather the effect of a changing
environment
and
have
again so this is just so the dream of
statistical prediction
just in terms of like tractability i
mean what do you think about
prediction versus just understanding
historical data
well
uh
you know i'm very much for trying to
predict in a sense that this is uh so
both useful and it's an ultimate uh
ultimate uh
test of our understanding so and you you
can split this into two parts so one is
predicting the outcome of a nice
controlled lab experiment
where
there is no way for the bug to
escape
selective pressure even though you know
even the chemostat they
find ways to you know stick to the walls
and
you know beat beat the experimentalists
but
uh but i guess what that
what i mean by this maybe is uh
um
less that my might
meet the eye
um
i guess i would say
i'd be willing to settle for
very
little
so think of weather prediction
so
uh
trying to predict the weather from you
know first principles you know solving
uh
turbulence uh
atmosphere ocean interactions
uh this is hard
but
forecasting works reasonably well and
the way forecasting works is
basically with a telephone and the
windsock
and
and the way it works is
you know you look out there you see the
cloud you see that the wind is blowing
away and you can predict
and of course there's a probability that
the wind direction will change between
today and tomorrow and then you won't
predict terribly well
but
i guess the challenge here is
can
by combining all of these strands of
thought
can we
devise
so population genetics equivalent
of
of a wind sock
just what exactly do we need to detect
say by looking at
genomic samples from
some existing population
what should we be looking for to make
some statement about what uh what
uh will be faced tomorrow
so
uh i'm not really keeping track of the
time
okay
so these are obvious questions
let me um
talk a little bit
okay so a little bit of review right so
this is a population given time
beneficial mutation comes in
and
its offspring are more successful at
surviving and they replace
their
unmutated
cousins
and
this beneficial mutation
fixates
that is to say
takes over the whole population but
then
before
it will fix the fixate it has to
overcome stochastic fluctuations which
will dominate its dynamics at
short times
i'm sure
you've heard about
this in the course of
of the week
and
the stochastic dynamics also known as
genetic drift
is
very well understood
since
some neutral theory of
kimura and there's another way of
thinking about this process basically as
stochastic brunching right at any given
uh time an individual that for an
individual in population there is some
probability of
having let's say two offspring
uh surviving in the next generation or
perhaps one or perhaps zero
and the variations on
this sort of model will all produce more
or less the same results
and what one looks at for example
is extinction probability and what one
finds is for neutral theory
this probability
approaches 1 as a function of time
and one can
generalize this and calculate the
probability
of
a given individual to have
n offspring after t generations and
their one finds a very simple
um so exponential distribution
um
with uh
expected number of offspring
conditional
conditional on survival
actually increasing linearly with the
time so that basically means that
right
while most of the population so this is
n
as a function of time so while most
in most cases
will be no offspring at all
there'll be
in the case where there are survivors
after time t
the expected number of copies
is of order t
so it's actually a rather interesting
and
and useful result
um so there are these sort of large
fluctuations
in in the process
and uh
um
so
intuitively then
is
immediately obvious that the probability
for the offspring
to take over the whole population that
basically means have the number of
offspring
um
equal to population size
right so we're looking for n equal to
uh capital n population size
and for that it has to survive roughly
for time over the n
and according to this little calculation
the probability of that happening is 1
over n
so
and
in the neutral population of course
that's pretty obvious there's no
difference between any of these
individuals so the probability of
taking over the whole population
uh basically has to be one over n it
comes out happily
and the whole thing you can generalize
and
calculate the stochastic dynamics
for an allele with some selective
advantage let's call it s and
you will find that
now beneficial mutations
have
a non-extinction probability
uh proportional well actually equal
to their fitness or so growth rate
advantage
and
once
the number of offspring rises to
sufficient number
that
then no
no longer likely to just be wiped out by
extinction
then essentially probability one they're
going to take
over the population unless something is
happening
so
i'm uh
the questions
is okay is it possible to account for
selective effects that can change the
population size so for example not
something that affects rate but
something that affects yield
uh
more certainly
so
um
so let's take
let's look at the process from another
useful angle so right now we're talking
about sort of forward
dynamics um
but
it is very useful also to think about
the genealogy of a sample
that
you may observe
in the present-day population
so
think of this as a
a sample of hiv genomes
but
but simply still let's just think of
this
as a population
and now see what's happening
on the
uh asexual in an
asexual population
as you look
backward in time
so
everybody has an ancestor
but some individuals are actually
sisters
right
and
in
this constant
in population of constant size that
basically means
that
as the time marches backward
the number of ancestors
in the population reduces
and invariably goes to
a single
most recent
common ancestor
in this very interesting
time to most recent common ancestor
and
that picture immediately means that uh
there are correlations among the genomes
of the present population which comes
simply from a shared
ancestry not that far back in in the
past
so
uh for the neutral case we know
everything about this coalescent process
called kingman coalescent time to
most recent common ancestor
basically twice the size of the
population
the average time separating
any pair of the individuals is just half
of that
and so on and so on all statistical
properties are known i think you've
already heard about that
why do we care about things like this it
actually tells us a great deal for
example knowing
the
coalescence time
for a pair
of of leaves
immediately tells us
how many genetic differences we have a
right to to expect right the mutation so
here i'm i start color coding mutations
so the probability that there is a
mutation separating these two
leaves
is basically proportional to
twice
the time
to their common
ancestor
alternatively
counting
the total number of
different alleles in the population
is
simply simply related to the total
length of this coalescent
tree
right which gives us another way of
estimating a mutation rate in in the
population
clearly
mutations that occur
in ancestors
with
lots of offspring
are going to appear at higher frequency
and again by knowing statistical
properties of the tree you can derive
the
the spectrum of allele frequencies
that you observe in in this population
so this is this is very very useful
the only problem with this
is
that actually statistical structure
of a neutral genealogical tree is very
different from a statistical structure
of genealogical tree in a population
with a lot of genetic diversity and a
lot of fitness diversity
and
so the most
obvious difference is that
the time to most common so these trees
are shorter so even though i'm showing
them here the same height
actually time scale for the coalescence
in the presence of selection is set by
the characteristic width of this
distribution
basically set by root mean square
fitness differences in
its distribution
and which typically
would be much shorter than the
population size
but uh
but then
if you look in a little more detail at
this tree you will
observe all sorts of other differences
for example
in the neutral tree
the first coalescence event
first coalescence events are the fastest
so the tree is kind of squashed towards
lower branches
and very different
in the tree under and the selection
and
there are also asymmetries in this tree
so for example
if you look at different clades
here they're roughly
comparable size
whereas brunching in
populations
on the selection tend to be very
asymmetric
so um
this is actually one of the areas that
that has seen
a great deal of recent activity driven
by statistical physics and
some non-trivial progress has uh been
made so it turns out that
quite generally for
a rather broad class
or really i should say broad broad class
of
underlying models as long as they
generate a lot of fitness diversity
the structure of of the coalescent
is
so statistically
similar to the cola to uh
the tree structures
that have been known in
statistical physics
having to do with relatedness of uh
so different uh
states of a spin glass so
maybe
scratch that
so these guys basically have
demonstrated that uh there's a certain
statistical universality in this
coalescent trees that relates them to
a known class of coalescence different
from the neutral one
and that of course is not the only
complication
in the presence of recombination the
genealogy is not a tree
and
people like yon have been
struggling with uh
um
actually
uh
reconstructing these uh
forests
um
for
populations with
the presence of recombination for
genomic data from
sexual populations
and uh
very recently we made uh
uh so an epsilon a bit of progress there
in uh sort of relating
the
um so the structure
of uh sexual genealogies
with the
the structure of
uh asexual genealogies for
local
um
patches of the chromosome
okay
so
okay
luckily
um
oscar has already set up
the conundrum for me so let's go back to
this problem of
figuring out
how the rate of evolution depends on
fundamental parameters such as
population size
and mutation rate
in so first in asexual populations and
oscar described two different uh limits
one is where mutation rate is very small
or the population is uh not too large
and then
beneficial mutations
come
one at a time
and
sweep through the whole population
sequentially
so
and then of course the rate of
adaptation is linear
in this n times mutation rate right the
total rate with which
beneficial mutations come into the
population right in the large population
beneficial mutations will occur in
different genomes and will compete with
each other that's this clonal
competition story and now there is this
much lower
rate of
adaptation because different mutations
compete
and most of them get uh get wasted
and
then
the conventional wisdom so this picture
so this uh
progress in understanding the case of uh
clone competition is
remarkably uh recent
so these papers are pretty recent
compared to
uh the fact that this picture i think
comes uh
probably from kimura's paper
uh this is sort of a very classic
picture but now we're gaining a little
bit more quantitative understanding
what's going on so conventional wisdom
um going back to the classics is that
in the presence of recombination clonal
competition will be
relieved
and uh
perhaps the linear so fast adaptation
will be will be recovered and we're
going to talk a little bit about that
but
and
remarkably
right now there are experiments where
one can actually
study this in detail and actually
validate the
uh
relevance
of uh
well
one actually observes that the
um
in reality we very often deal with the
situation where clonal competition
and genetic diversity are actually
important so
um
we would like to have
this sort of general description of
dynamics in highly diverse populations
and i'm going to take
two minutes to uh
present you the following
nightmare scenario basically as a
provocation
so
let's take any pair of us
and
i'm told that we're different in about
a million polymorphisms
and now suppose that all of these
polymorphisms
are what i would call
legally neutral
which is to say
that whatever their contribution to
fitness might be
it is undetectable
right which means it is smaller than one
of the population size
okay so
again i'm told that the relevant
population size for humans
is uh 10 000 right
taken over
sufficiently
long
time window so
now let's uh
do the arithmetic
so
let's say that
each of this million contributes 10 to
-4 to fitness and some make this uh tiny
positive contribution some make a tiny
negative contribution so we have to add
them up with variable sign so it's of
incoherent diffusive sum so
the rms
of
the combined effect is going to be
square root of a million times 10 minus
4 that's 0.1
that's a gigantic effect
right so
that immediately would
define a very fitness diverse population
and all this diversity
at the moment
is made entirely
with the smoke and mirrors right
because by definition we'll never be
able to isolate
this uh
polymorphism
and
measure its contribution to
to fitness
so um
if this so
right you will never be able to study
this the way
molecular genetics
has been
done
basically precisely by identifying
mutations with large effect and then
studying everything about them
identifying
the role of the gene
in
the pathway and
perhaps even understanding
the effect this mutation has on
the structure of the protein and
how that explains its effect in the
pathway so right
never a single paper will be published
about
polymorphisms like this
and that's sort of where statistical
physics view kicks in
and says well
uh
you know we understand thermodynamics
pretty well even though we don't give
every molecule a separate name
and sometimes
from sufficient complexity where you
have lots of players that contribute
very little
um certain
emergent simplicity
might come from
and uh you know of course this is a
ridiculous oversimplification because we
know
that there are those large effect
mutations
and
molecular biology and genetics
has been very effective at
discovering those those big effects and
there there is no escaping
those big effects
but
but perhaps
there is also this
underlying
mass of tiny little effects
and in trying to disentangle the whole
whole system we have to
have a model
of the collective effect of these lots
of tiny effects
and uh
at the very least
as a kind of a new
null model
to replace the neutral model
so that we don't think of the big
mutations
riding on the top of
the neutral everything else
but rather big mutations
riding on
top of
this non-descript
gas
of tiny little
contributions to diversity so
that was uh my attempt to provoke you
and uh
uh the next thing i will actually
stop philosophizing and we'll start
talking about uh calculating all things
so i think it's a good place to stop
there's a lot's actually have to go so i
think people should just take off and
you know everyone needs to go
run don't worry about it um but if
people want to keep uh
bugging for questions go for it
and also mob him and try and take him
out to lunch
you